so would you say you still spend about
300 days a year writing Empire no no I
was I was the first two seasons of
Empire I was very active and then season
three I switched to consulting and went
made rep when the Rye so I have I'm now
season three and four I'm you know I'm
still at the executive producer on it
but but I'm not nearly as hands-on as I
was in the first two seasons so you
probably couldn't have written rebel in
the Rye and also Empire at the same time
well I wrote I think I wrote rebel in
the Rye the first couple drafts before
Empire happened and it actually Empire
happening slowed my progress in getting
rebel in there I made because Empire got
made so I ended up working on that but I
ended up directing a lot of episodes of
Empire so that was an amazing experience
for me to transition into directing just
couldn't have been a better way to to
really learn that craft because you have
to move so quickly and and I'm have
plenty more to learn but it was a great
it was a great start for me when you're
writing and I know you said you had this
writing day where you have your
breakfast you kind of do a few things
get get a lot of like housekeeping what
would out of the way is it easier to
write in New York versus LA or the place
doesn't really matter
well I love New York City I love being
there I'm just so happy there so for me
I can write anywhere and that's kind of
one of the fun things about writing is I
can be anywhere in the world and I can
write and it's actually pretty cool to
be in some random city somewhere and
some random coffee shop and you're
writing and it's it's like how often
does someone have a job that they can do
anywhere in the world I mean that's a
lot of fun and I'm perfectly productive
in Los Angeles too I just I just love
being in New York and it's a it's just
exciting place to be so can you relate
to JD Salinger's process in terms of
once he sort of crossed over into
meditation and all of that where he
needed to really barricade himself can
you relate to that or um I definitely
don't barricade myself at all actually
right in public places I don't like
being in a quiet room by myself I have a
certain amount of abd and being in a
quiet room Izone out
I'm less productive so I actually like
having people around me one of my head
said I listen to music I write two movie
scores so I'm just listening to movie
scores and people are around and there's
an energy and and I find it very helpful
and I just helps me focus but that's
just me so I I the you know the the
isolation of what what mr. Salinger did
is kind of the opposite of of how I work
for new writers I know they're told to
get feedback from other people and I was
just reading an lamotte's bird by bird
and she talked about like writers
conferences and how they can be helpful
but at the same time sometimes the same
you know slashing to the edits is also
stabbing the screenwriter a little bit
you talk about the kindest way to give
somebody honest feedback so you're
actually helping them you're not
wounding them so that they won't go on
well I think that the best way to give
feedback and I'm very very much rely on
feedback and I need notes from people
and it helps me see problems and it's
very important part of my process is
getting feedback but I think that to
keep I mean good feedback is when it's
just about the script it doesn't get
personal it doesn't you know talk about
bigger ideas of whether you can do this
or not area of talent or not where it's
literally just about how to make this
script or this story better in areas
that are problematic and I think that I
don't I think it's really important when
someone's getting feedback that they
talk to a few people that they get
feedback from from maybe three people
because there could be feedback that
someone gives you that they're very
passionate about but they don't know
what they're talking about that it's bad
feedback that they're just not good at
giving feedback there's a lot of people
that aren't good at giving feedback
right so you want you want a few
opinions and for me when I start hearing
from two or three people the same
problem they're having well there's
probably a problem there and there's
probably something I need to address and
one of my favorite parts of writing is
when I take a problem and then I fix it
and then it's good
that's that's so exciting because you
have something that was bad that's now
good and just it's just it's like you
have a hole and instead of having a
ditch you have a statue there instead so
it's a very bet I can only get that get
there when by getting feedback from
people
you